god bless the palestinians and god bless  the united states thank you very much he  shoves the president of montenegro  philip vujanovic out of the way  and then we fell in love okay  now really he wrote me beautiful letters  they're trying to take you out with  [ __ ] okay  president donald trump has been  impeached again making him the only  president in history to be impeached two  times we appreciate it very much tim  apple trump called troops who died  losers  and suckers i hope they now go and take  a look at the oranges or the oranges of  the  investigation the beginnings of that  investigation trump uh had protesters  tear gassed and dispersed with horses  for donald trump to walk to saint john's  church and be photographed holding up a  bible